- So I've had a lot of comments
on the channel over the years, being like,
"Joey, you should share
your hair loss journey."
As if I have some epic tale,
a dramatic story arc,
infused with life lessons,
a coming of age tale, but in reality,
it's not something I've
really thought about much.
Hair loss was always in the cards for me.
Growing up, my dad really
didn't have much hair
and my two older brothers
shaved their head
due to male pattern baldness
when I was around 12 years old.
When they did that at the time,
I didn't really think much of it,
probably for like five minutes, I said,
"Oh, that's kind of weird.
You look kind of dumb,"
but then the novelty wore off
and they were just my brothers,
the same brothers that I
always knew since birth,
but when it was my turn and
I started seeing symptoms,
I wasn't so nonchalant about it.
Growing up, I always looked
older than I actually was,
even right now that fact rings true.
I'm 25 years old.
A lot of people think I'm like 32.
So when I was a kid, I
really took pride in the fact
that I looked older than I am,
that way I could boss other kids around
and seem like an adult
before I actually was,
even though I didn't have two brain cells
to rub together back then.
So when I was 16 years
old, my barber told me,
"Hey, you're starting to lose your hair."
I kind of freaked out internally.
It's like the "SpongeBob" meme
where he's calm on the surface,
but internally losing its shit
and I was like, "You know
what, this is kind of a bummer.
Now I'm gonna look really old,
like I'm going to look 40 when I'm 17."
But I didn't really do anything about it.
I started to notice that my hair
was starting to recede at the temples,
but it was slow enough
that I didn't feel the need
to do anything about it.
I was just hoping and praying
that my hair might last me
somewhat into university.
Oh, we should probably just fast forward
to photos of me when I'm 18 years old.
This is sort of high
school graduation territory
and you can start to see
that I'm receding at the
temples fairly significantly
for an 18 year old.
I definitely do not have like
a squared off head of hair
at 18 years old.
And this is the summer
before I went into my
freshman year of university.
So into university, you
can see that my hair,
it's still there, you know,
it's still fairly thick on top,
but definitely lots
more temple is showing.
If I had actually done something about it,
I would've had a decently
full head of hair to work with
and potentially experienced some regrowth
to the point where I would almost have
a full head of hair right now.
You and me would be talking,
having this conversation,
actually, it's a one-way conversation,
I'm just talking at you,
but we would be doing this together
and I would have hair on the
top of my head, but I didn't.
I was in denial.
I just said, "You know what,
I don't wanna worry about it.
I don't really care that much."
But I think I did care.
It did affect me.
And we'll get into that
a little bit later.
You can already see by
the end of my first year,
there's a lot of temple there
and I don't know what I was
doing with my hair at the time,
but it was not doing me any favors.
I was slicking that right
back, kind of curling it back.
You could tell, this
man is losing his hair,
like a middle-aged man at 18 years old.
And I think at the time it
affected me subconsciously
whether I was aware of it or not.
So I'd start to wear hats
a little bit more often,
trying to cover it up, but
the hair loss got worse.
Here's me at the start of my second year.
There's a lot more forehead.
I'm starting to keep
my hair shorter on top,
because I noticed it would just draw
a little bit less attention to the fact
that I was balding and I'd
keep my hair very short
on the sides as well.
Just trying to do some techniques
that didn't look absolutely ridiculous.
I didn't wanna look like I
was trying to hide the fact
that I had a receding hairline.
I kind of wanted it just to
look clean and out of the way,
but then it got worse and obviously,
you know, that's what happens
with male pattern baldness.
It doesn't just get better.
So here's me playing piano
at some gig or something
with my brother, Eli.
I was cutting my own hair at that point,
buzzing it all the way up to the sides
and then leaving it lengthy on top.
It kind of is an optical
illusion from the side.
It makes me look like I'm kinda going
for that Mohawk look, but
it's not a great look.
I do look very pointy.
My entire head kind of
looks like a crescent moon.
I think my third year is when
I should've bit the bullet
and shaved my head.
I even started a YouTube
channel in my third year
and it was called, Better
Ideas and I had hair
and you guys can tell, it
doesn't look that great.
It was starting to do that
weird androgenic alopecia thing,
where it was starting to
get thicker on the sides,
like right around the ears
and then kind of getting
a little bit puby on top.
Sorry, mom.
It just wasn't a very good look.
It just didn't look fresh.
It wasn't the best version
of what I could be doing
and here's the weird thing psychologically
as to why I didn't shave my head.
It wasn't because I
wasn't aware of the fact
that I would probably look better
if I just bit the bullet
and shaved my head,
but it was just the fact
that I had lived my whole life with hair
and it was almost like I
didn't want to say goodbye.
I attached a part of
my identity to my hair.
I almost felt like I wasn't ready
to become a new person by shaving my head.
I wasn't ready to present to the world
that I'm a new person now.
I finally let it go.
I'm no longer in denial
and obviously you don't think
these things consciously,
it's just sort of a subconscious
identity crisis you have.
You're kind of at a crossroads.
Do I just let go of my hair
as a variable in my life
or do I continue to hold onto
it for whatever it's worth,
despite the fact that it's
not serving me anymore?
But I pressed on for
at least another year.
This was when it really started
to just not look so good.
I definitely have this sort
of like bowl shaped thing
going on on my head, two semi-circles
and from the top, it was starting to thin
right on the crown.
So here's the year
before I shaved my head.
Everyone's looking suave.
Here's all my brothers.
Here's a bald brother of mine.
Here's another bald brother of mine
and then some non balds, look
at this non-bald right here,
non-bald right here, non-bald right here.
Then here's the funny thing about Daniel,
is actually he was
starting to recede here,
but he actually did something about it
and now he has sort of,
you know, more hair,
like way more hair than he
did when he was losing it.
That's what happens when you're proactive.
So good on Daniel for not denying reality
so he can improve upon it.
Either way, my hair's really
looking rough at this point.
It's definitely like an
advanced Jude Law look
and I don't have Jude Law's face,
so it doesn't work as well
for me as it does for him.
So at the end of my fourth year,
the summer between fourth and fifth year,
I finally bit the bullet
and I shaved it off.
All right, let's film this video.
So I shaved my head.
I think it looks a lot
better, to be honest.
I was really postponing that.
My hairline was like,
I mean, you can see where my hairline is
and I had like a little
bit of hair kind of like,
that I'd do this with and
then you turn my head,
it'd be all thin up here.
It looks like I'm not trying
to hide anything anyway.
And I sent some photos to my
friends and family being like,
"Yo, look, I shaved my head."
And they're like, "It looks good, dude."
That's it, you know,
I've met with some friends that summer
and they'd be like, "Oh,
you shaved your head."
I'm like, "Yeah," they're like,
"Yeah, it looks good, man."
That's it, you know, all that buildup for,
you know, 22 years or whatever it was,
led to the reaction of people being like,
"Oh, it looks good."
And then treating me like
they've always treated me.
You know, it doesn't really...
It's not a thing, like,
it just doesn't matter.
And what I've learned
over this whole process
is that nobody cares, even
when my hair was receding,
unless you had somebody else
who was really self-conscious
about their hair,
they would probably compare
it with you and be like,
"Oh, that guy's receding a
little bit more than me,"
but all in all, you know,
nobody's thinking about your hair
more than you are.
And when you shave it off,
it's not like a big reveal
and it's like the "Princess Bride"
where you have this giant glow up,
there's a glow up in the "Princess Bride"?
No, "Princess Diaries", I think.
Yeah, it's not like that.
Nobody cares, nobody cares
before you shave it off,
nobody cares after you shave it off.
Your hair is just dead protein
on the top of your head,
do what's best for you.
In my opinion, if your
hairline is receding
to an advanced degree, it
probably will look better
when you shave it off,
but do I care if you shave
your hair off or not?
No, so just make the decision
based on what's best for you.
And funny enough, since shaving my head,
I feel like I have actually
gotten more confident,
especially when meeting strangers
and it's totally a subconscious thing,
because I don't have
to think about the fact
that I have an incomplete hairline.
I don't have a hairline anymore.
I literally can't have a bad hair day.
I can also walk faster,
because I'm more aerodynamic.
I can also tell when it's
raining quicker than anyone else.
I can jump higher, swim faster,
I've basically become a
god, but in all seriousness,
the moral of the story,
I guess I can conclude
from my hair loss journey,
is that no one really thinks about you
nearly as much as you think
about yourself, not even close.
Most people, most of the time
are not thinking about you
and that might be a little
bit of a hit to the ego,
but it's the truth.
Most people are mostly
thinking about themselves.
So to think that people
are like sitting down
at a Christmas dinner,
thinking about Joey's hairline
is such a joke, but that's how our brain,
we always think that's gonna happen.
The same could be said,
not just about hair loss,
but about a mole that you
happen to have on your upper lip
or a zit that you have
on your forehead one day.
It's a huge deal to you maybe,
but really you're just kind
of like a background character
in most people's lives
and they're not really
thinking about you at all.
So why would you put
yourself through the trouble,
the mental distress,
to let that affect you?
So, yeah, that's the story
of my hair loss journey.
I hope you guys got something out of this
or at least just had some
fun getting to know me better
and you know, kind of picking apart
a little bit of my history.
Maybe you could learn a
thing or two from this,
but if not, maybe you'll
learn a thing or two
using today's video sponsor, Skillshare.
Man, I'm getting good at this.
For those of you who don't know,
Skillshare is an online learning community
with thousands of classes,
covering dozens of topics.
Everything from
photography to videography,
to learning to color grade
or tell stories better,
creative writing, cooking.
Do you wanna learn how to cook?
You can learn how to cook on Skillshare.
Do you wanna learn how
to code your own website
and make thousands of monies?
You can learn that on Skillshare too.
Whatever you're into,
there's probably a class
for it on Skillshare
and whatever class you
choose to take on Skillshare,
it will be extremely practical,
because every class on Skillshare
is designed for real life.
It's super easy to take
whatever you're learning on Skillshare
and apply it directly to
your real life pursuits.
That's why I always
like to mention the fact
that I'm constantly taking videography
and editing classes on Skillshare,
because that's my real life pursuit.
I want to enhance the things
that I am interested in
and Skillshare is just an awesome resource
to help you do that
and Skillshare is doing this awesome thing
where the first 1000 of you
who click my link in the description below
will get a one month trial
of Skillshare Premium.
So make sure to take
advantage of that offer,
learn something new,
explore your creativity
and as usual, have a great time.
And if you liked this video,
make sure that you actually
hit the like button,
because when you hit the like button,
the algorithm shoves my bald head
into other people's homepages,
helping them out, which also helps me out,
so it's kind of a win-win
for everybody involved,
this whole Better Ideas community
can grow and that's good.
That's a good thing.
And if you're lurking here and
this is the thousandth time
that you've watched one of my videos,
consider hitting that subscribe button.
Other than that, thank
you so much for watching.
Make sure to check out the second channel,
because there's lots
of fun content on there
and I'm a lot more casual,
like I was in this video on there,
so if you like this style of video,
hit up the second channel,
it's a great time.
Other than that, thank
you so much for watching
and we'll catch you in the next video.
(soft jazzy music)